is what i find to be absolutely
fascinating netflix takes on texas
attorneys analyzed the outlandish fight
over cuties the hollywood reporter is
basically
they're talking about a story in which
this month there was supposed to be a
hearing in texas netflix is facing a was
was to face a criminal charge for
i think it was like child lewd behavior
or something there was a a federal
ruling that overturned the statute from
texas about children and lewd activities
or lewd behavior
so the the d.a who
strangely enough as the story goes
played
played the character spider in the film
school of rock his name is lucas babin
brought the case brought the film cuties
to a grand jury and asked them if it
depicted children in
child
adult films to put it mildly and a grand
jury returned four felony indictments so
now what's happening is we're seeing
with hollywood reporter story
they're bringing in these lawyers who
are like oh it's a first amendment thing
you know they're obviously critiquing
the sexualization of children and we're
now in this strange world where
when a d.a brings the film before a
bunch of regular people and says was a
crime committed they say yes
yet the establishment media the left as
you would call it is defending a film in
which they took four young girls
i don't care if you think it's their
actors or actresses whatever actually
taught these little girls to do these
dance moves had them do it in an
extended scene that was like three
minutes long have scenes where there's
clearly adults grooming these children
and then said but it's a critique it's
fine
this is the this is the
you know if i if i can get i can broaden
the the conversation a little bit
outside of this
clearly we live in completely different
realities with whatever the
establishment in the left is from
regular people to i'm kind of thinking
of george carlin's obscenity push
against obscenity i understand i i'm you
know morally i felt like that movie was
a little too sexualized i think you made
the example earlier it's like
in order to explain something you don't
have to like show it necessarily like
something really vile you don't want to
like put it in front of people
prove that you're doing it you know when
when shakespeare wrote plays all the
violence happened off stage you don't
need to see it to know what happened
it's a great point yeah
i mean those little girls actually doing
those scenes in front of a hole i would
imagine mostly male adult male crew
it's just gross i mean what were the
parents or anyone thinking well so so i
think there's one part of this story
that easily
proves they know they're doing something
wrong in the hollywood reporter they say
conservative circles have rallied behind
criticism of the movie for sexualizing
exploiting children babin's father texas
congressman brian babbin us under ted
cruz and a group of more than 30 house
republicans have called on the doj to
prosecute netflix this and other calls
by conservatives to investigate the
making of the movie prompted netflix to
apologize for inappropriately
sexualizing actresses in marketing
materials
the marketing materials were scenes were
clips from the movie yeah they were
pretty nasty and the issue is that it's
not a critique because they actually did
it they actually did these things with
little girls
um as kelly j was saying you know in
front of an audience of crew
they paid them for it you know they paid
the children to do these things
um
there was a lot of incentive to do a
good job three no one pleased the people
who were
asking them to do it i brought up carlin
because he in order to show the obscene
thing that he was wanted to make more
publicly agreeable he would just do it
he would say it he would say the words
that were horrendous and at the time and
this is kind of like so the metaphor is
like the child sexuality is the dirty
words of the 70s it would be different
if it was an animation it would be
different if it
was yeah which is also disgusting and
weird
it would be different if it was adults
playing children
right
that would be difficult or they could
just like the kids could have come out
on the stage
and then it could it could have showed
the people's faces yeah and then not
actually put these little girls in that
situation carlin got arrested for saying
the words but he did it anyway he was
like i'm just kidding but he was saying
words he wasn't and he's
depicting the abuse of children which is
different right and even if you say
things like if you if he had
said out loud what was being done you
know what these girls were doing and
being made to do if you say it out loud
that's also different than actually
doing it so it's what makes it i think
more similar to um like a pornographic
situation
is that just like in adult films the
acts are actually performed will be
crazy is if it was about child murder
and the movie was all about showing kids
getting killed
there wouldn't be any emotional backlash
like there was about child sex
would they be different would the
children actually be killed no it would
all be acting just like this is all
acting no no no no no but it's not
acting once you're doing the actual
thing right so like i mean even if
you're acting like you're doing the
thing you're actually still doing the
thing
it's yeah and it's like if those if that
was a snuff film if you're talking about
a snuff film
that would be there would be a lot of
backlash of that well i mean and
i wouldn't call it backlash i would say
like pitchforks and it would be you know
it would be illegal it would definitely
be illegal to do like i think this is
you guys see cuties i haven't seen it
you know i wouldn't watch it i didn't
watch it i i see
some of the bits
yeah
so the issue for me was i watched
enough of it to where i said i i'm not
interested in watching this film
and uh
yeah i'll put that i did not watch the
film as if to say like i sat through the
whole thing but i watched the relevant
bits to a certain degree and was just
like this needs to be turned off it's
it's disturbing dude they got a kid that
looks like alexandria ocasio-cortez that
the main 12 year old actor looks like a
sexualized cortez it's well insane
talk about sure but that's that's that's
like a french film yeah what a weird
question
yeah so cuties is the reason that i
cancelled my netflix subscription i was
like this is unacceptable sorry i'm just
not having it i don't feel like giving
money to a company that thinks that this
is tolerable
i was more angry when they pulled star
trek the original series
imagine it this way ian imagine they
made
let's make a film critiquing uh children
doing drugs
and will literally give kids crack and
film it and then building like a reality
show
that's the issue so it's more like that
i think than what carlin was but is it
was it a reality i didn't see the movie
was it a reality show it wasn't it was
fake it was it was always fake but i
mean look what do you mean like the
movie wasn't they didn't actually go
into a club and get 12 year olds dancing
there no no no no
and they probably had to sign a contract
and their parents had to agree
to this group but it was sexual it was
so they had to
whatever they were doing acting or not
it was a sexualized performance so it
doesn't really matter whether they were
acting they were still actually doing it
with their real bodies so the funny
thing is the response from a lot of
these people on the left is that the
final scene in question where the little
like 11 year old girls or whatever are
doing the sex dancing is that the
audience is disgusted by it and i'm like
but you all literally watched it too
and they actually had these little girls
do that
so what
show someone being grossed out by it and
all of a sudden you're allowed to do it
that doesn't make sense to me if you're
criticizing it you wouldn't do it right
also when we do when we have um like tv
shows or stuff like that in the u.s
usually
adults do it like
90210 which is the first thing i could
think of
all those actors were in their 20s right
and they were like
having sex and doing whatever they
weren't actually having sex but they had
like all the make-out scenes and stuff
but everyone was in their 20s the same
with like you know riverdale or any of
those shows what if they're all in their
20s what about super bad i i brought
this up when i was talking about this
earlier today there's a so christopher
mintz plus i think was like 16 when they
filmed the movie and there's a scene
where he's you know he's having sex with
some some woman or whatever and
apparently his parents had to be there
and sign off on it i'm wondering you
know
this is a 16 year old we know high
school kids are doing things but is it
still does that make it better at all
because i'm actually wondering i'm
wondering yeah as you're saying that i'm
sort of i'm wondering about that as well
i mean i still thought it was messed up
realistically a 16 year old boy and 11
year old girl are worlds of different
when it comes to sexuality that's true
right one is going you know has gone
through puberty and is still doing it
and the other stuff is exploitative
though yeah yeah filming a 16 year old
boy that's certainly not i would never
sign off on that for my kids if i had
been a 16 year old boy i would have
launched at that opportunity
short but so here's what would your
parents have gone for it yeah they
supported whatever my choices my parents
did not do that
i honestly feel like this along with you
know what that the fl the whole florida
controversy over don't say gay i it
really does feel like it's not in the
bill right it's not but but you know
their their their perception of it or
what their critique is
you look at
super bad there's a scene where a 16
year old kid is hooking up that's in the
movie and it's not like graphic or
anything but it's clearly a scene acted
out by this kid and they want you to be
like ah they're 16 year olds you know
you know we know high school kids are
doing stuff then you end up with shows
like big mouth which is like 12 was a
show like 12 and 13 year olds yeah that
show is messed up it's a cartoon though
it's a card everyone's like oh but it's
nick kroll it's like famous actors
pretending to be kids and it's just
cartoons and i'm like
it's still weird do you know do you guys
know the show big mom i don't know it
you've gotta watch it really right it's
worth it yeah yeah it's the most overly
sexualized cartoon i've ever seen
children
and then he's got like a little deep sex
demon on his shoulder that tells him no
it's not little it's a massive it's
crazy
yeah i
netflix got critiqued uh criticized
critique is probably the wrong word for
it because there's an episode where it
shows two little girls walking around
naked and it shows a whole bunch of
naked women and they said no no no we're
trying to tell little girls to be okay
with their bodies that's why we're
showing it and people said look dude
it's a cartoon there were no actual
children here then what happens you end
up with movies like cuties where it's
like now you have actual little girls
doing it but oh come on it's a critique
just like and i'm just like yo why don't
you guys like stop yeah well it's
interesting too because this stuff is
coming up in books too that are now you
know available in schools there's this
whole controversy with this book
genderqueer um by a person called maya
kawabe i think i don't know how to say
her name exactly right but um
but this book has been
talked about by parents all over the u.s
um that this book has child pornography
in it and that it has like depictions of
you know all these crazy things so i
bought the book um because
i had been writing about it and i was
like i should really take a look at this
book myself
and it is rather disturbing not just for
the reasons that the moms that i know
were complaining about it but also for
this journey of this young girl who
comes to realize comes to decide that
she's not
a girl at all that she has like these
other pronouns that are like uh
they start with ease em ear yeah that's
it e m ear and so the book eventually is
the story of this person who grows up to
be a comic book artist who's 25 has
never had sex has no interest in sex is
binding um
is binding their breasts
and is teaching middle school and
planning to come out to the middle
schoolers as an asexual
a eem heir and this is all like very
affirmed and it's all very you know
couched in this language of hyper
positivity
uh
the main character in this book hates
their body
is terrified of going to the
gynecologist which if you're a woman
like you gotta show up at the
gynecologist at a certain point at least
a bunch of times in your life to make
sure that you're not dying from a whole
bunch of reproductive issues that can
kill you um
so you know this person is terrified of
that terrified of being touched all of
this stuff
and it's it's in the language of joy and
uh
spectacularness look i i can
you know understand adults who want to
live however they want to live you know
someone's over 18 and they decide they
want to you know juggle oranges all day
or like dress up like a giant duck i'm
going to be like literally i don't care
what you do man you can go mind your own
business but it's the it's the it's the
obsession with children that i find
you know
yeah like why does your why do you need
your middle school teacher to come out
to you and tell you that they hate their
body
and
it's like a
really small children
in this fashion but there is a there is
an overwhelming surge to break the
frontier and boundaries of kids just
totally erode all safeguarding not allow
them to use words that are literal and
mean something
and the sexualization of kids whether
it's cuties whether it's this cartoon
but it's like
it's as if you're doing something
remarkable if you're trying to
enforce this onto kids
it's so messed up it's um yeah it's
almost like we've destroyed our culture
to the point where there's no way for
children to gauge when they're adults
so we just have to decide that they're
adults from the very beginning and can
understand this stuff so kids are
learning about gender identity
before they know what sex is why uh
well i i don't think it needs to be
asked but to the left
you know my question is to the the to
the left in general
why they think there's an age of consent
now the issue is i honestly think the
left
is is as opposed to that idea of an age
of consent i think
many of these people are just
they're just
ignoring that issue for now
but i think if you were to actually get
these people in private and ask them
they'd probably advocate for really
really messed up stuff i think that's
correct and i think we've seen that
i think what they're doing is they're
eroding our culture with you know things
like cuties and defending it and i'm
like could you imagine this film being
made 15 20 years ago well 15 20 years
ago or 20 years ago anyway like tipper
gore would be pissed right and she was
the
she was the second lady or whatever the
vice president's wife who put the
explicit advisory lyrics on
you know my jane's addiction album we
see all those uh things on twitter have
you ever seen like maps the the the
minor attracted person stuff
or that's foundation prostasia the
prostatia foundation which is all about
uh
advocating for
uh
pedophiles to be accepted in society
you have to wonder about what these
people's true goals are at the end and
then you know you have to wonder about
uh why people like
epstein kind of just disappear traffic
why why max
elaine maxwell gets convicted but
convicted of what where where what is
what did she do i mean we're talking
about a crime that involves two people
right where are her clients
why they all get away with it and then
it's really funny how it's just like
anybody who brings that stuff up is
clearly a conspiracy theorist and you
know they must be making things up and
i'm just like dude the netflix thing is
really really fascinating because i
don't think they're gonna be able to
walk away from this one a grand jury so
apparently the feds are like we're gonna
we're gonna have a hearing on this in
june or something or july over whether
or not you can this this stands
but i have a feeling that the da is
gonna say to the federal judge we
completely agree with their critique
yeah and and agree you know you
shouldn't sexualize kids okay but they
did it's such a shame though don't you
think with netflix because they've
really stood up for dave chappelle they
are willing to sort of allow
supposedly controversial opinions and i
i really was you know i totally backed
them for that i think that's brilliant
but and then they do this and you're
like oh come on please i don't i don't
know if they actually back dave
chappelle to a certain extent you know
the last special that dave did was
heavily focused on trans people it's
like a really it's really weird yeah
dave did a special he mentioned uh he
had jokes about trans people he got
attacked heavily for it and it's it
seemed like it consumed him and so he
ends up yeah his next special ends up
being this kind of like
it was very defensive yeah it was linear
it was nearly a ted talk to be fair yeah
no seriously yeah where he was like you
know and he was like i guess people just
don't understand the joke so i'm gonna
stop doing them right they got him what
did you think of that what did you think
of the whole chappelle thing uh well i
have issues anyway because i
i i think he's incredible for walking
away from all that money and uh keeping
his dignity and credibility all those
years ago
but i'm not really a great big fan of
his humor some the way that he talked
about candice erwins
i just can't really get past that
um but
yeah i think
it's bizarre that comedians ricky
gervais is the same they sort of tell a
joke and then explain the joke and like
why when have you started doing that
just tell a joke if it's funny we'll
laugh and if it's not we'll move on but
you saying oh this is a joke because
actually i'm doing a bit of wordplay and
i'm doing this and please don't cancel
me it's like no just have the
bravery thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there